im golf von mexiko gibt es eine region
die kein leben zuletzt es ist wie im
weltraum eine gigantische todeszone
es handelt sich um eine art w doch das
ist viel zu harmlos ausgedrückt
dauershow verschwindet fische und alle
anderen meeresbewohner fliehen oder
sterben direkt die komplette
artenvielfalt ist zerstört jetzt haben
forscher und forscherinnen eine
gruselige erkenntnis gewonnen
die todeszone ist so gigantisch wie nie
und nur einer hat
wir menschen was genau die ursache für
diese erstickende brühe in den ozean
ist und wie man das problem beheben kann
jetzt winken kleine pfützen herzlich
willkommen
die todeszone im golf von mexiko
erstreckt sich vor der küste des us
bundesstaats louisiana und war von texas
bis florida aktuellen berechnungen
zufolge mit sie 23.000 quadratkilometer
und hat damit die neuen fläche des
saarlandes seit vielen jahren tritt
dieses phänomen im golf von mexiko
immer wieder auf und zwar jeden sommer
rund um die mündung des mississippi
plus es doch jetzt schlagen
meeresforscher alarm denn in den
vergangenen fünf jahren betrug diese
todeszone im durchschnitt lediglich
15.000 quadratkilometer auch wenn diese
zahl weit über der maximalen größe
lucky die us-behörden als unbedenklich
einstufen übertrifft die aktuelle
ausdehnung alle prognosen der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
noch im juni hatten sie gemutmaßt dass
die fläche dieser todeszone wohl etwa
21.000 kilometer beträgt eine prognose
die wie damals als pessimistisch
eingestuft hatten
leider weit gefehlt die ökologischen
konsequenzen in der todeszone sind fatal
in diesem bereich des kaufs von mexiko
existiert kein leben mehr kurzen die
ihre muscheln und fische fliehen oder
sterben direkt die komplette abend
vielfalt vor ort ist das wird mal ganz
abgesehen von den wirtschaftlichen
schäden denn fisch und schrumpfen
beispielsweise sind natürlich nicht
mehr möglich und diese todeszone an der
amerikanischen golfküste ist bei weitem
nicht die einzige weltweit haben
forscher die achtung und 400 todes von
identifiziert studien besagen dass diese
vor allem in den vergangenen 20 jahren
entstanden sind
eine studie aus dänemark geht davon aus
dass sich die zahl der ozeanischen
todeszonen seit 1995 um ein drittel
erhöht hat in den 70er jahren gab es
wohl noch nicht einmal 100 todeszonen
nun sind es also 400 touristen weltweit
und wenn man ihre flächen addiert
ergibt sich die größe von neuseeland
krise alle todeszonen haben eines
gemeinsam sie liegen sehr küstennah und
das was das leben in ihnen unmöglich
macht ist niedriger sauerstoffgehalt der
fachbegriff dafür
die proxy dieser die praktische zustand
wird durch menschenhand verursacht das
ist nicht von der hand zu weisen konkret
entstehen wurde zu und dadurch das
flusswasser viele nährstoffe in die
ozeane transportiert düngemittel rechte
und abwässer aus sehr viel zu und den
städten beispielsweise die ganzen darin
denn die trat und phase sorgen im
meerwasser für eine eigenständige
gigantischen ausmaße so groß dass sie
sogar auf satellitenbildern erkennbar
sind
nach dem absterben sinkt diese alge
masse zum meeresgrund und wird dort von
mikroben zersetzt und auch deren
population explodiert beim abbau der
alten benötigen diese bakterien
sauerstoff dieser wird dem meereswasser
entzogen und die position entwickelt
sich und wird immer größer eine studie
der us umweltorganisation mit
liegt nahe dass vor allem einzelne
wenige agrarkonzerne für die
erstickende boje im golf von mexiko
verantwortlich sind riesige flächen
werden im mittleren westen der usa von
diesen konzern bewirtschaftet die
hauptsächlich fleisch produzieren so
viel steht nicht mehr auf der weide
sondern frisst kraftfutter aus mais und
soja für dessen anbau dünger
eingesetzt wird und land umgewandelt
wird die stoffe gelangen über den regen
in den mississippi und andere flüsse
und von dort in die meere aus sie nutzen
sie für die tierzucht werden zudem bio
kraftstoffe gewonnen auch ein riesiger
faktor wird noch mehr angebaut
denn neben den ausscheidungen der tiere
die über düngung der ozeane verursacht
dass ich immer mehr tote organische
substanz auf dem meeresboden anreichert
kehrt jedoch wie immer wieder das
ausmaß der todeszonen wird jährlich
größer ein teufelskreis denn die
aktivität der mikroben setzt zudem noch
nickel wasserstoff frei und belastet das
übrigens noch mehr
die aussichten sind also im wahrsten
sinne des wortes ziemlich trübe
clijsters wir menschen die schultern die
todeszonen abend und die konsequenzen
sind russell und haben am ende auch
wieder folgen für die menschen setzt
die ostsee beispielsweise ist weltweit
eine der größten sauerstoff am
meereszone der sauerstoffmangel
verhindert dass sich der dort vermehren
kann
denn seine eier ersticken und auch
andere küstengewässer weltweit eignen
sich nicht mehr als kinderstube für
verschiedene fischarten das gestaltet
nicht nur den fischfang immer
schwieriger sondern sorgt gleichzeitig
auch dafür dass tiere auf den oberen
plätzen der nahrungskette leiden
beispielsweise robben oder klein walle
doch was können wir dagegen tun am
effektivsten wäre es den einsatz von
düngemitteln zu beschränken
das zeigt ein beispiel von schiesser
an der ostküste der usa seit sieben
jahren sollten die mittel nur noch unter
strengen auflagen eingesetzt werden und
mit dem sauerstoff der dann wieder und
mehr zurückkehrt kehrt auch wieder das
leben zurück ins wasser
das ist wirklich immer wieder
beeindruckend wir können etwas ändern
wenn wir nur wollen und wenn ihr kein
video mehr zu diesem und anderen themen
verpassen wollte dort mir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit mehr
monsterwellen auf den ozean gefahr auf
dem wasser also auch über wasser lauern
die gefahren draufklicken und es ein
bisschen mit der angst zu tun bekommen
würde ich mal sagen ansonsten bis dann
gleich dran